yeah this is the natural next step right
when Nick Cage was on his roll the Holy
Trinity of Nicolas Cage movies which I
imagine is different depending on some
people but for me the rock is part of it
actually maybe the rock should have been
first I don't know I'm just winging it
here look can I say there's no real
roadmap I'm just wandering anyhow let's
review Michael Bay's best movie like by
far by a clear mile let's do it
[Music]
so the rock was directed by Michael Bay
another mid-90s Nicolas Cage action
movie this is Michael Bay came out
swinging I mean it's not like this was
his first movie still I find the rock so
enjoyable that I either thought one of
two things one I liked the rock back in
the day and then if I rewatched it now I
probably wouldn't like it or two the
Michael Bay that directed this was
abducted by aliens and they replaced
Michael Bay with a Michael Bay alien
robot who does Michael Bay movies now I
mean not that they're all terrible some
of them have fun I'm just saying it
feels very different so in the Rock Ed
Harris plays general Hummel and he's
taking the tourists on Alcatraz hostage
there's a ransom demand and a group of
Navy SEALs and a chemical freak I'm a
chemical super freak actually okay fair
enough a team of Navy SEALs and a
chemical super freak and Sean Connery
Hoshi has a unique knowledge of that
place she was formerly a guest here they
have to infiltrate Alcatraz and then
incursion underwater to retake an
impregnable fortress held by an elite
team of US Marines and possession of 81
hostages and 15 guided rockets on the VX
poison gas better than any break down I
could possibly give and so yeah now
welcome to the rock course what I like
about this movie
first of all Nicolas Cage and Sean
Connery they just weirdly work for me
and it's not like Sean Connery and
Harrison Ford type chemistry but still
their dynamic really works there are
senior citizen and a lab rat and really
it's all on their shoulders to get the
job done I don't know if that's perfect
or so weird that it somehow became
perfect but it's perfect I love how
badass Sean Connery is and just how
nerdy Nicolas Cage's I love the banter
between the two sometimes Sean Connery
is just kind of an [ __ ] sometimes
she's just busting Nicolas Cage's balls
point is I thought the Panter was good
the few things yeah the feet thing yeah
I'm having kind of a hard time
concentrating can you do something about
it
like what but the scene stealer folks
this is the thing the person that really
makes the movie for me it's ed Harris's
general Hummel
this is a very humanized villain to the
point where it's like an antihero he's
big boss or something that might not be
the last Metal Gear reference I give in
here the rock came out when Ed Harris
was generally America's good guy you
know is always the good guy
granted Ed Harris has played scumbags
since the rock when the rock came out I
remember the whole thing look whoa
they're making our good guys bad guys
that this particular bad guy he's a bad
guy well that doesn't mean he's bad guy
you can tell he's a conflicted person
the entire point of why he's doing this
is because there were soldiers who died
under his command
and he just wants the families to be
paid up for these soldiers that the
Pentagon just kind of brushed aside
swept under the rug and forgot about
first of all that's something that's
just easy to get behind he's the
antagonist in the movie who's honorable
there's an honor to the man he respects
the lives of his soldiers and actually
the lives of the opposing soldiers he's
not bloodthirsty he's doing what he
feels he needs to do be it the wrong
thing for the right reasons you made a
terrible mistake and more of our
brothers have died in vain damn you for
forcing me in his position
and you're able to understand it because
even he's conflicted by it he felt like
I I'm really gonna enjoy firing these
rockets into the city the fact that he
is an honorable person leads to
dissension among the ranks and leads to
some people questioning his authority
it's really complex [ __ ] these are the
moments I love in the rock I think of
the rock I love these moments in you man
arguably my favorite moments in the
entire movie well first of all one that
does have a shootout and that's the
shower sequence testing is all sorts of
tension but also great monologuing you
tell your men to safety their weapons
drop I am pretty sure that's him on the
box art of the original Metal Gear game
but also that scene where John Mason and
Frank Hummel just talked I mean granted
there's a hostage situation going on
there but it's just dialogues I don't
quite see how you cherish the memory of
the dead by killing another million that
is good [ __ ] and you see the war of
their ideology and their philosophy tree
of liberty must be refreshed from time
to time with the blood of patriots and
tyrants thomas jefferson patriotism is
the virtue of the vicious according to
Oscar Wilde just a couple of great
actors playing a couple of compelling
characters talking with each other it's
just an amazing scene and it has nothing
to do with action it's all I need my
Michael Bay action movies I guess I know
the other side of the coin of this
movies yeah it's a Michael Bay movie so
you're gonna have action you're gonna
have action sequences where most people
probably would have just gone from point
A to point B and Michael Bay is like
wait a minute
Sean Connery is gonna have a nice
conversation with his estranged daughter
yeah which means you have to drive there
yeah which means we can make an action
sequence there make the drive a chase
sequence alright well it looks like San
Francisco's about to get bade and I
bring this up because a movie about a
group who has to infiltrate Alcatraz
because of a hostage situation and you
know take out the guidance chips on the
Rockets you don't really start going to
Alcatraz for that until about an hour
into the movie there is something that
drags on in this movie that's the common
denominator
Michael Bay movie ever that I've seen in
the history of ever has that common
denominator they're all just a bit too
long because they drag at some point in
the movie in the case of the Rockets
somewhere in the first half of the movie
I feel like some of these scenes could
have been shaved off I like the setup
with Sean Connery I like all of that and
for the most part it makes sense I just
don't think there had to be an action
sequence there could have dangled the
dude over the roof I mean like piece and
Nicolas Cage could have been like hey
buddy where's his next to Kin great and
then just met up there that whole action
sequence could just be taken out even
that super intense scene near the
beginning of the movie it does make
sense
Nicolas Cage is that his job there's
this chemical bomb alright they need to
defuse it but it serves to show how good
Nicolas Cage is at his job more
importantly serves to show you what the
syringes do I mean they mentioned them
in passing when they're going to
Alcatraz but in this case it's you
really get how important those syringes
are but the most important part of the
set up the part that changed my life
first of all it's because on the beetle
maniac and second please sound better
that was a scene I was like wait dead is
that true my dad was like yes I actually
have that album not the first pressing
or anything but you weren't asking for
it right
lots of good so in the end the rock has
the action Michael Bay isms and
sometimes especially leading up to all
the Alcatraz stuff it goes a bit much in
some parts it's like all the actions
going down and we're not even at the
rock yet but it's Sean Connery Nicolas
Cage and Ed Harris the three of them
they make the movie for me the
compelling dynamic of the decorated war
hero that's going against the country
he's served for the sake of the memory
of his fallen troops and their families
a former British operative who was just
locked away and they threw away the key
who's the only one who really knows how
to navigate Alcatraz because he's the
only one who ever successfully escaped
and a lab nerd played by Nicolas Cage
which it's like he was like look I've
been a lab nerd let me do something else
alright Nicolas Cage you work out grow
your hair
we got a role for you it all just really
work for me and I'm glad that watching
it today it's still good
it remains Michael Bay's best movie and
still a great time worth watching and
worth buying on blu-ray
I saw the rock have you watched it have
you watched it recently what Eve
about it whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]